- Everybody, time for our first guest.
I'm so excited.
Usually on "The Voice",
I'm confident I'm gonna win.
Pretty confident.
Blake and John, please, easy.
I've beat them.
But this woman is something else.
She's like a giant storm
that's just gonna come in and kill us.
She, she's an,
really,
she's an amazing vocalist
and funny as hell.
And you can also see her with me,
this season on "The Voice"
on NBC starting tonight.
Give it up for Ariana Grande, y'all.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh, you look beautiful.
You look beautiful.
You look so pretty.
You're wearing it.
Wait, you're...
So,
I have,
this is, by the way,
this is,
this is what it sounds like
like on "The Voice".
Like when we're, the
coaches are coming out,
that, that's what it's
supposed to sign for all of us.
- Blake got so pissed.
- [Kelly] But it doesn't,
yeah, Blake,
Blake was like, "I don't
want to follow her anymore."
But it's also, by the way,
what was it like the
first time you moved here?
We're having like LA,
we love LA week.
So what was the first
time you moved here like?
- The first time I came to LA
was for my Victorious callback
and I was so nervous, but so excited.
- You were young.
- [Ariana] I was really young.
I was 14, but I had never
been here until my callback.
And then my mom was like,
"Do you think you have it?
You could really do this?
We'll get a place.
Well, you know, should
we get an apartment?
Do you think?"
- That was a good investment.
- They kept us waiting for a long time.
There's like a long time between callback
and then the next one, and the next one.
And we were staying at a
hotel and she was like,
"Should we just get an apartment?
Do you think you're gonna get this thing?"
And I was like, "I hope
so. I have no idea."
Thank God, because what
if I didn't get it?
And then she was like,
"Well, we have this lease
for the next six months."
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] It's fine.